so Syria has given the U.N permission to
use two more border crossings from
Turkey to allow much needed Aid to be
delivered to rebel-held areas
humanitarian supplies have been slowly
getting into the Quake affected
Northwest the UN says that more than 50
truckloads of Aid have been delivered
through what has been the sole Crossing
it was allowed to use it's now been
eight days since the earthquakes hit
Syria and turkey killing more than 37
000 people
we have a team of correspondents
covering the disaster across turkey and
inside Syria but first let's cross to
xenohoda who's on the Tokyo Syrian
border um Zeno so news that you more
unaid is going to be allowed into
opposition-controlled areas
foreign
yes the decision to use more border
crossings means more lifelines for the
people inside Northwest Syria syrians
desperate for much needed assistance the
Northwest as well as other cities in
government-controlled areas were badly
hit during last week's earthquake now
many are seeing this as a surprise
really because during the course of the
war the Syrian government with the
backing of Russia has prevented the
United Nations and the International
Community from using border crossings in
fact they've closed four of them in
recent years and only left one open
Babel Hawa now the United Nations will
be able to use two more Crossings among
them Baba salami behind me so the United
Nations is welcoming this move there
were high level talks in Damascus
yesterday some believe that you know
backdoor deals were were made at the end
of the day the International Community
is pouring a lot of money and relief Aid
into Syria and the U.S treasury a few
days ago lifted some sanctions on Bank
transfers into Syria for for Relief AIDS
but more than that many believe this
cooperation coming from the Syrian
president is part of a campaign to
really
exploit if you like the situation in
order for him to regain a political
legitimacy so the world engages with him
and this is what's concerning the Syrian
opposition they're saying that you know
waiting for Assad to agree to open
border crossings was wrong on the part
of the International Community they
should have just used these border
crossings without his approval and
without the approval of the United
Nations especially since you know people
are desperate in need of assistance so
tell us a little bit more about the
broader relief effort in Syria
foreign
well it has been inadequate especially
in the northwest of the country
something the United Nations
acknowledged the UN Aid relief Chief
himself saying we failed Syria we failed
the Syrian people since that earthquake
playing loads of Aid have been landing
and government-controlled airports
Damascus Aleppo the United Nations
operates in government-controlled areas
and they were delivering much needed
food supplies and shelter for for those
affected by the Quake but in the
Northwest just a few trucks entered
enter the country in fact according to
the white helmets this is a Syrian Civil
Defense volunteers they they called off
the search and rescue operation days ago
because they said countless of lives
have been lost because they didn't have
the heavy material heavy machinery
needed in order to rescue people
underneath the rubble so there's a lot
of anger in Northwest Syria they feel
that the world has abandoned them the
International Community did not provide
them any support reports and now they're
very concerned that the International
Community is dealing with a man they do
not consider legitimate the president of
Syria who has been doing his best to for
the International Community to accept
his his reign in in the country all
right Daniel thanks to that is a
reporting there from the techie Syrian
border thank you
well eight days after the two
earthquakes survivors are still being
pulled from the rubble a short while ago
three people including two brothers were
rescued for Karama maras let's go to the
capital anchor now from where Cinema
cosiolu joins us so it seems so still
extraordinary Tales of survival and
rescue more than eight days on
exactly it's like a record for the
rescue workers who are in the field
trying to rescue people and they say
it's a miracle it's the 100 nearly 200
hours the ninth day and the rescue
workers haven't given up on the people
yet so we had two brothers two young
Brothers uh having been pulled out from
under the rubbles and we just heard that
a third person has been rescued this
morning last night again we heard some
middle-aged people even old people
having been rescued from under the
rubbles that's why everybody believes
this is like a miracle currently there
are more than 250 000 workers on the
ground trying to rescue the people but
you know the damage is a very big Nick
we have thousands of buildings that have
collapsed and so many people are under
the rubbles they are able to rescue the
people who are on the top floor
especially in the high story buildings
but the rescue workers the miners the
fire executors who are in the field of
the health workers they are working so
hard
to save their people to save their
neighbors even the people that they
don't know that's why we are hearing
extraordinary stories and of course this
is a hope despite the Lost Circle has
been has been through according to
official figures right now the number of
the people who lost their lives is more
than 31
600 and more than 158
000 people have been evacuated from this
area but the work is still underway and
the officials have been saying that
after a week the certain rescue
operations are going to be completed and
by the end of February or let me say by
the beginning of March new constructions
to replace the collapsed building is
going to begin this is the the situation
in the field and the feedback from the
Turkish capital Ankara
all right thanks very much
province is one of the hardest hit parts
of turkey natashika name is in the city
of Antarctica with more on the recovery
operations there
and Takia is now a city
ruins
station as to why it has been decimated
one man tells us we are psychologically
broken there are no Services people have
been told to evacuate yet some remain
that's because they are holding a
soul-shattering week-long vigil waiting
for their loved ones to be pulled out of
the rubble holding on to the Hope
however infinitesimal that they will be
granted a miracle rescue
our loved ones need us to be strong my
beloved nephew and his wife are under
the rubble do you know the tiny line
between hope and despair I'm going
through this for the last few days
between miracle and reality the people
who remain are also living in the rubble
they say they've been given food they've
been given clothing but they still don't
have shelter they complain that the
search and rescue operation was so to
begin here in antakia they say it took
about three or four days after the
earthquake hit to begin in earnest
since the earthquakes hit more than a
week ago there has been a national
Reckoning over the well-known use of
shoddy construction material and the
lacks enforcement of building codes in
compliance with earthquake engineering
standards
warnings were issued amnesties given now
people are angry
it's wrong to blame the government
although they've made mistakes I think
all the responsibilities on the
contractors the ministry of justice has
issued 134 arrest warrants arrested
three people and police are searching
for more than 100 suspects in connection
with building code violations as for the
people here in antakya they say they
know this diverse City with ancient
Roots will rebuild but given the
historic proportions of this Devastation
they know it will take a very long time
Natasha ganim Al Jazeera and Takia
turkia